please welcome to lay moon fry
i love you so much and
i watched the documentary
kid 90 and it's so powerful it's so
good um it's still made me cry already
i'm in tears well i was with all the
same
people and in the same scenes at the
exact same time
you're born in 1976 right yeah
and of course we were little together
and then we grew up
in in in this wild world right
i mean i i the first time i ran away
when i was i don't know six or seven i
ran to your brother's house shawn
who was in 18 i remember that i remember
you telling me that story
was like hi i ran away to your house and
he was like okay come in and then my mom
came walking through the door an hour
later and i was like sean
you backstabber but one of the things
that really struck me is because you
were an artist and had
a video camera in the 90s when no one
else did you were a total pioneer
the reaction especially with the fact
that
all of the peers were hollywood kids
no one thought that the camera was a
weapon
right because it was pre-social media so
everyone was just being themselves and
their authentic
selves and just being kids and and i
don't think it's it's just a hollywood
thing for me
that was what was so important is like
we were just kids growing up together
so it was just these these very
authentic relationships of people that
were like family
that also happened to be artists one of
the things that i loved hearing you say
was that you were really happy
when you were working you know like the
punky brewster years
were positive and it's funny because
when you talk about some of the
difficulties of
navigating these types of lives and jobs
it's like the baby gets thrown out with
the bath water there are really positive
things and i'm so glad
that you talk about that will you talk
about that now i love that
absolutely i mean i was so fortunate to
have
a really incredible experience i had
begged my mom to get into acting
you know watching my brothers and my dad
i wanted to be an actress so badly and i
was really shy and then somehow
in front of the camera like i i came out
of my shell so it was something i really
wanted to do
and uh and we had pogo sticks on the set
and scooters and
so it was a very kid-friendly experience
which i think was very different for me
than it was for
many of my peers and so i was
i was really grateful and my mom also
really made sure i always had my
childhood i went to summer camp every
summer
so i never felt like i didn't have my
childhood
and then it was only once i started
going through puberty
and went through my awkward stage in
which i went from being this little girl
to then all of a sudden people treating
me much
more like an adult uh and and that
then of course led to so much insecurity
and
self-doubt and all of those things that
we so often go through as
as kids growing up allow me to give a
little context to this
take a look so the roles that i was
getting
offered at 13 14 years old
are all roles and i'm
13. i went from living this
amazing childhood to
almost being forced into adulthood
that happens i i can corroborate it it
happened to me too
and you're not told that
that's not okay for people to do or
there's not a real
conversation box on the corner of the
street with how you're supposed to deal
with it
and then you dealt with it in your
own ways you know you took matters into
your own hands
yes you know my back was hurting i had
all these medical things and i ended up
doing
my breast reduction and i was like i'm
gonna help make a difference and i was
so
righteous in a way and and then it
became you know
kind of public humor and something that
that was
always brought up is as part of who i i
was and i was really
proud of it it's just interesting how
others made
me feel about it and i think the same
things go on
with with young people today magnified
times a million
because of social media and living lives
through filters and i think it's
it's really um important that we
have this dialogue because it's timeless